moi j'ai quand même entendu plusieurs
fois déjà depuis le début du quinquennat
nous parler avec force des sujets
régaliens fallait réduire l'immigration
fallait lutter contre l'immigration
clandestine
on a vu qu'en fait les chiffres n'ont
fait que se dégrader sur ce point là
donc je pense que c'est une nouvelle
manoeuvre destinée à montrer qu' il est
plus à droite que les républicains en
particulier
après vous savez les chiffres sont têtus
et à partir de là quand on annonce par
exemple des déploiements très fort de
policiers nationaux sur le territoire je
dis simplement est ce que monsieur
macron les craies ex abrupto ou est-ce
qu'il est prend ailleurs pour les
changer de place
donc on voit bien que dans la réalité
non jugera sur les faits les français
aussi d'ailleurs mais il ya un aspect de
communication qui ne trompe personne et
non en fait son jeu c'est dès le départ
d'essayer de flinguer les républicains
c'est très clair il a nommé un premier
ministre issu demeurant pour ça quelques
ministres qui ont quitté leur famille
politique pour le rejoindre dans ce but
là donc on n'est pas surpris si vous
voulez la seule difficulté c'est comment
est-ce que après quelques années de
gouvernance où on a vu la violence
augmenter et la déstabilisation d'un
certain nombre de cités on arriva à
redorer son blason finalement a regagné
en crédits c'est ça son équation
mais moi nous nous faisons très
clairement le pari que les français
aujourd'hui ont vu emmanuel macron
depuis plus de trois ans à l'oeuvre et
qu'il n'est pas crédible sur ces sujets
il a beau les proclamer haut et fort
le bilan parle contre lui je suis assez
proche quand même de ce que tu
travailles que christian jacob a mené
des prêts maintenant un an et demi à la
tête des républicains on n'a pas
forcément beaucoup parler quand on a
beaucoup bossé et on a travaillé sur les
thèmes vous avez parlé du régalien vous
avez parlé de l'économie aujourd'hui je
pense très honnêtement c'est mon
sentiment que la droite républicaine est
en train de trouver une voie qui n'est
pas si mauvaise que ça